die debatte ist neu entbrannt es geht um
unidentifizierte flugobjekte kurzinfos
die das us-militär mittlerweile als uhr
habt also als unidentifizierte phänomen
im luftraum bezeichnet diskutiert wird
über sichtungen von mysteriösen
phänomenen die möglicherweise zitat die
nationale sicherheit bedrohen auch der
ehemalige us präsident hat sich jetzt
zum thema ufo sichtung geäußert was
steckt wirklich dahinter und sind wir so
außerirdischen zivilisationen dicht auf
der spur
wir fassen die aktuelle lage zusammen
klicks uns im feature los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen der ehemaligen navy
pilot ryan grey's ist sich sicher
zusammen mit seinen kollegen hat der
zitat über jahre hinweg und täglich
unidentifizierte flugobjekte in
eigentliche militärisch gesicherten us
luftraum geortet und gesichtet ein
enormes risiko für die nationale
sicherheit so rein grapes in einem
interview mit dem us sender cbs
es geht um sogenannte apps die abkürzung
für an identität als phänomenal was
übersetzt soviel heißt wie
unidentifizierte phänomene im luftraum
und rein waste ist sich sicher dass sie
tatsächlich um das handelt was bislang
als unfug bezeichnet wurde
sowohl gegenüber dem pentagon als auch
im us kongress und der us zeitung new
york times sagt grave diese dinger waren
da draußen am himmel den ganzen tag und
um ein fluggerät in der luft zu erhalten
bedarf es größeren mengen an energie
angesichts der von uns beobachteten
geschwindigkeiten sind zwölf stunden in
der luft es stunden länger als wir
erwarten würden drohnen egal ob
militärische oder zivile herkommt wie
wir sie kennen schließt er somit also
als erklärung für die beobachteten
phänomene aus und die sichtungen fanden
nicht nur in der vergangenen zeit statt
sondern gates zufolge bereits seit
vielen jahren zusammen mit seinem team
des fa 18 kampfjets hätten sie bereits
die tat seit 2005 sind über zwei jahre
hinweg nahezu täglich ungewöhnliche
manno wir fähige und unidentifizierte
flugobjekte über militärisch gesperrtem
luftraum südöstlich vom virginia beach
detektiert diese mysteriösen sichtungen
fanden also bereits so häufig statt das
base und seine crew diese bereits als
fast normal
doch genau das gegenteil sei der fall
sagt der ehemalige pilot in dem
aktuellen interview mit dem us sender
cbs
im sommer letzten jahres hatte das us
pentagon bereits drei videos
veröffentlicht die lange zeit in der
prüfung waren dann aber offiziell
kommuniziert worden waren wir haben
darüber berichtet diese aufnahmen
entstanden vor 17 2004 und vor sechs
jahren 2015 vor vier jahren also im jahr
2017 wurden sie dann von der new york
times gelegt auch hier traten
kampfjetpiloten unter anderem auch rein
gates als zeugen auf diese waren
losgeschickt worden um die sache ein für
allemal aufzuklären die beiden piloten
berichten wirklich erstaunliches demnach
haben sie das mysteriöse etwa 15 meter
oberhalb der wasseroberfläche draußen im
pazifik aufgespürt es seien nicht nur
rund 13 meter lang sondern habe sich
auch in einer unvorstellbaren
geschwindigkeit fortbewegt allerdings
erst als die piloten sich immer weiter
nähert dazu einer der piloten in einem
interview mit der times es beschleunigte
sich wie nichts was ich jemals gesehen
habe
die piloten seien dann weiter zu ihrem
treffpunkt geflogen etwa hundert
kilometer entfernt dort entdeckten sie
das objekt dann wieder
demnach muss die strecke in sehr kurzer
zeit zurückgelegt haben 2015 ereignete
sich wohl ein ähnlicher vorfall in
us-medien berichteten kampfpiloten dass
sie während ihres trainings einsatzes
auf dem flugzeugträger ziel der
roosevelt immer wieder unbekannte
flugobjekte über der amerikanischen
ostküste gesichtet haben wollen jeden
tag seien objekte in der luft gewesen
und das über einen sehr langen zeitraum
von bis zu zwölf stunden
sie sprechen von einer hyper
schallgeschwindigkeit in bis zu 10.000
metern höhe und das ohne sichtbaren
antrieb auch abgaswolken hatten die ufos
demnach nicht hinter sich hergezogen
nach ansicht der piloten ist eine sache
ganz klar
menschen können nicht dahinter stecken
denn dafür seien die beschleunigung viel
zu unvermittelt passiert und das in
einem raschen wechsel mit abrupten
stopps dazu sagt der pilot reinweiß in
einem interview mit der new york times
geschwindigkeit bringt dich nicht um
anhalten bring dich um oder
beschleunigung ein place fordert nun
noch einmal mit nachdruck dass solche
sichtungen von solchen ups oder emas
ufos nicht weiter als zitat seltsame
verschwörungstheorien angesehen werden
sollten sondern als zitat reales risiko
die nationale sicherheit reales risiko
für die nationale sicherheit dazu sagt
reyes während es taktische chips eines
anderen landes wäre das ein großes thema
wir ignorieren den fakt dass sie da
draußen sind und uns jeden tag
beobachten
nun gehen die spekulationen von vorne
los handelt es sich um geheime us
technologien um feindliche und
bedrohliche spionage plattformen oder um
etwas ganz anderes von dem wir bis dahin
noch keine ahnung haben und
möglicherweise auch nicht von dieser
erde ist klar ist nur nicht nur ein ace
befürchtet hier das schlimmste
auch louis l iz.de und der jahrelang das
geheime ufop untersuchungsprogramm des
us-verteidigungsministeriums geleitet
hatte macht sich sorgen auch er
befürchtet dass die ops unsere
sicherheit gefährden könnten zitat
stellen sie sich eine technologie vor
die 600 bis 700 fachkräfte erreicht und
aushält und 13 tausend meilen pro stunde
schafft eine technologie die das rad
arbeiten kann und sich sowohl durch die
luft als auch im und unter wasser und
vermutlich auch durch den weltraum
fortbewegen kann die zu leben aber keine
offenkundigen anzeichen für irgendeinen
und bekannten antrieb auf zeigt keine
tragflächen besitzt keine veränderlichen
oberflächen und dennoch den natürlichen
effekten der irdischen schwerkraft
trotzt diese technologie ist allem was
wir bekanntermaßen in unserem eigenen
militärisch technologischen inventar
besitzen absolut und haushoch überlegen
und so hat der us kongress die
geheimdienste und das us pentagon
aufgefordert einen aktuellen bericht zu
schreiben thema der aktuelle stand des
wissens und zudem eine beurteilung der
daraus resultierenden gefahrenlage dazu
sagt christopher möller und der unter
den us präsidenten bill clinton und
george w bush stellvertretender
verteidigungsminister für geheimdienste
war was das pentagon bestätigt ist dass
es tatsächlich flugzeuge gibt die
eingeschränkten luftraum verletzten das
ist passiert und passiert weiter und wir
wissen nicht woher sie kommen wir
verstehen die technologie nicht erwartet
wird dieser bericht für ende juni
fraglich ist allerdings ob das eh schon
dann in der finalen version vorliegen
wird und ob es wirklich schon so zeitnah
antworten auf diese vielen spannenden
fragen geben kann im vorfeld hat sich
jetzt schon der ehemalige us präsident
barack obama zum thema geäußert und zwar
in der late late show mit dem us
talkmaster james corden was obama denn
von den aufnahmen des us militärs halte
auf
denen die unidentifizierte flugobjekte
zu sehen seien zunächst antwort unter
barack obama noch ein spaß begleitet von
einigen lachern zitat wenn es um aliens
geht gibt es dinge die ich und er nichts
sagen kann
doch im späteren verlauf des interviews
sprach barack obama auch ernstere worte
nach seinem amtsantritt habe es sich
nach informationen vom geheimdienst
erkundigt ob es ein labor gäbe in dem
raumschiff und aliens aufgebahrt werden
zitat nach ein bisschen recherche habe
er die antwort nein erhalten und weiter
sagte er im interview mit dem us
fernsehen
aber was wirklich wahr ist und jetzt im
ernst ist gibt filmmaterial und
aufnahmen von objekten im himmel wovon
wir nicht exakt wissen was sie sind wir
können nicht erklären wie sie sich
bewegen eine wirklich gruselige sache
also und doch gibt es auch immer noch
fachleute die zweifeln umso wichtiger
dass eine lückenlose aufklärung
stattfindet denn schließlich gibt es per
se auch viele andere erklärungen für
seltsam erscheinungen oder lichter am
himmel das wetter mit dior schauer oder
beispielsweise flugzeug tests könnten
dahinter stecken es gibt viele fachleute
die ufo-sichtungen auch mit technischen
fehlern oder neurologischen überlastung
der piloten erklären so auch der
astrophysiker lehnen galopp im interview
mit der new york times vermutet er
einmal technische fehler im code für die
bildschirme wenn es videos oder fotos
von unbekannten objekten gibt könnten
diese oft durch vögel oder insekten
erklärt werden die in einem speziellen
winkel heranfliegen
aber auch linsen reflektionen dem
objektiv sind oft wahrscheinlich für das
was man dort angeblich sieht eine sache
gibt es noch die ich an dieser stelle
klar stellen wird die diskussion um uhr
ups oder ufos hat erst einmal gar nichts
mit unserer suche nach außerirdischem
leben zu tun denn hierbei haben
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
momentan primär winziger mikroben und
bakterien auf fernen planeten im visier
hier geht es also nicht um lebensformen
die möglicherweise sogar fliegende
objekte bauen und bedienen können dass
es sich bei den ufo sichtungen
tatsächlich um außerirdisches leben
handelt das sich mit hyper
schallgeschwindigkeit fortbewegt ist
mehr als fraglich
dieser zweifel ist aber keineswegs
gleichzusetzen mit einem zweifel an der
existenz außerirdischen lebens doch die
wahrscheinlichkeit dieses aufzuspüren
ist sicherlich sehr viel höher wenn wir
uns weiter auf andere dinge
konzentrieren beispielsweise auf die
analyse der atmosphäre von exoplaneten
ufo sichtung pentagon veröffentlicht
offizielle videos stand der ufo
forschung anklicken hier anschauen und
diesen kanal klicks ums abo nieren
lebens dreimal pro woche ausführliche
und aktuelle science videos wenn er also
nichts verpassen wollt dieses video
ansehen und abonnieren und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran